so hi everyone as Cindy introduced me
I'm I have a PhD in physics background
in physics and computer science I'm a
network scientist working as a postdoc
at social cognitive network's academic
research center at Rensselaer
Polytechnic Institute but today I'm
going to speak to you about my work as a
NASA data not so I send it in detail
introduce to you the nest data this
initiative where you can work on open
access dataset and collaborate with
other data nodes and also with data
scientists within NASA and we have all
these cool weekly meetings where we get
to see what the NASA community employees
are working on and we get to brainstorm
and come up with collaboration ideas and
things that we can work together on and
on top of that we can also work on open
access datasets and collaborate with
each other the NASA data not and get
some suggestions and ideas from data
scientists and the chief knowledge
architects from NASA on what is their
interest and what topics they are
interested in so the open as a platform
if you're going to log into the platform
you're going to see that they have made
available over 32,000 dataset and this
comes as initiative from all the other
government agencies as well to make
publicly available datasets and to make
to increase visibility and transparency
over government agencies so that's why
they made publicly available these
datasets and on top of that nest also
made available some code repositories
and
API so you can access them but this is a
continuously growing platform so if
you're going to log into this platform
open nasa.gov you're going to be able to
see the datasets code repositories and
api's that are currently available and
this is going to be constantly
increasing and you're going to have
access to all this information
and if you're going to if you're
interested in this as Cindy also
mentioned this is going their current
application process is currently open so
you can apply for the spring session and
you can become an esse date or not and
work on this but even if you're no sense
of data note you can still work on this
because they are publicly available for
everyone now among the data sets we also
have the open esse metadata which you
can find here in the JSON file format
which is going to be give you basically
information of all day on all these 30
2008 assets and if you just want to have
an idea of what these datasets contained
there are some Mars rover sound data
Hubble telescope image collection NASA
patents and picture collection from
telescopes and so on so there are many
information out there and this is just
like five of the 32,000 but what I'm
currently interested in and one of my
projects here what I'm going to talk to
you about is to understand the data set
collection and for this I'm going to
analyze the NASA metadata which contains
information about each of these data
sets it's about their IDs title
description keywords and all the other
information that you can find so if
you're interested in this metadata you
can download it from this link and it's
going to give you a JSON format of all
these information for each dataset and
the question is these data so each data
is handled and is maintained by a
different bureau within the NASA and
which Bureau is going to have a person
who is responsible of maintaining the
NASA data online and giving it the
titles and descriptions and keywords and
the question that NASA is trying to
understand to answer is whether these
descriptions overall these 32,000
datasets are descriptive of the content
and this human assigned key words
whether they are actually
reflecting what is in the data itself
because one of the big projects that
they are trying to work on is to develop
the search engine with which anyone can
just hit in a keyword who is not working
at NASA and who is not familiar with the
NASA terminologies and can retrieve
meaningful data set from this data
collection but the question is whether
these human assigned titles descriptions
and keywords are indeed representative
and in order to do that we have to
analyze so the questions among others is
which of these features is best to tie
together the data in order to analyze it
how do we label groupings in a
meaningful manner and we also want to
see how we can visualize them and how we
can obtain additional information from
looking at connectivity patterns and how
these terms co-occur together and so on
and of course the main question is
whether these descriptions and keywords
are representative of the content so for
this reason I'm going to use natural
language processing with Python to
analyze how actually these humanists
Hank keywords are meaningful and whether
we can actually build a search engine
and based on this we can accurately find
information through the data sets or we
actually need to do some improvement
so for natural language processing if
you are not familiar with techniques and
packages there are several packages out
there my current analysis is using NLT
Kay and you're going to be able to find
after that this presentation on github
on that link my Jupiter notebooks and
you'll be able to reproduce with that
all the data that I'm going to pretend
you here and all the result so the first
thing that we're doing when we have this
tremendous amount text we're going to
generate these word clouds to see first
the frequency and to visualize the
frequency of the terms within the data
so for that we're going to build these
word clouds of course I used rockets and
spaceships because NASA and you're going
to be able to see what are the most most
frequently occurring keywords and with
what we can see is that it data set
Earth's ocean acquire spectral bands so
if we look at the titles we again going
to see similar information but here
we're going to see that the most
frequently occurring words in the clouds
are basically project names and the
project names are not very informative
for people who are not aware of this
project so for our analysis I further
removed these information when I did the
cleaning of the data and we also if we
look at the keywords we can see science
atmosphere optics ocean and all these
keywords that are very nicely revealing
which are the most frequently occurring
and of course if you want to take this
next step further you can also do
Jupiter and Juno and whatever else
visualization you want and if you like
this customized visualization technique
Andres Miller has on github this package
word cloud and basically just need to
get the stencil and then load your text
and you can obtain all sorts of word
cloud shapes that but of course the word
clouds are nice and pretty but they are
not very meaningful for our analysis so
in order for us to do further analysis
on the on the text we need to do like
with any data set cleaning and
pre-processing now the text
pre-processing requires several steps
first of all we need to move everything
to lowercase we need to convert all
words to either lowercase or uppercase
depending on what
want so that we can treat the data with
capital D and data with lowercase as
identical words and you also want to
remove special characters called the
numbers which you can do with regular
expressions and that I removed all the
NASA
codes for project codes that are not
going to do meaningful for people who
are not familiar with these project
names and then of course you have to
check for misspellings and to remove
those and then stop words you have to
because these are the most frequently
occurring words and they are meaningless
so you want to remove them from your
analysis and then of course you need to
do lam attestation so that you break
every word to a basic form you're going
to if you have a pure love systems you
want to break it down to system so that
the machine learning tool is going to
understand the algorithm that you're
talking about the same tool and the same
word and then the same thing you're
going to do the motivation if you want
to break it down to the root of the word
so in this case if you have compute
computer and computation you're going to
bring it down to compute this is going
to be the one word and then you're going
to do tokenization you're going to break
down the text to the smallest part
because basically this is what we're
going to analyze the word and you're
also going to have to do POS tagging
which is basically are going to give
look at each word in the sentence and
see if it's an it's the noun an
objective or and what's its position in
the text and then depending on what's
the dimension of your text you're also
gonna have to do dimensionality
reduction now in with Python there are
many ways to do stemming and
dramatisation here I just showed with an
LT case some of the methods that you can
use but limitation is a more useful tool
in my opinion because you're going to
still have a valid word if you remember
the compute
example the compute is going to be the
root of the word but it's not going to
be a valid word if you're studying it
and now that we looked at what are the
basic cleaning methods we're going to
look at the term frequency which is
basically what we looked at one with it
word cloud analysis but they are
actually two we didn't have the numbers
so we saw that some words are bigger
which means that they occur more
frequently but we don't see how much
more frequently so therefore we're gonna
do this term frequency analysis to
actually plot the number of occurrence
of each word and then we can see that
the top keywords for example you can see
here and how many times they occur on
the x-axis and the same thing can be
done for the description and the same
thing can be done for the title so just
to reiterate what I was saying at the
beginning what the metadata contains so
these three information on keywords
description and title of each data set
are given our human attacked by a person
working within the Bureau who is a
response that is responsible of the data
so what we want to see is basically
whether these keywords descriptions and
titles are unified throughout each
32,000 data set and whether they are
also descriptive of the content whether
the keywords
describe what we have seen in the
description and whether we can retrieve
information based just by searching
through one or the other and moving
further the term frequency is
interesting one we see look at it in a
text but since we have 32,000 data set
we want to see how what is the frequency
of terms with respect to the data to the
data sets to the number of documents and
for this the best another a better
approach is to analyze the tf-idf which
is going to give you the term frequency
is the inverse document frequency so
you're going to get to see what is the
importance of a term throughout all
these data sets not just throughout one
data so a term that is going to appear
very frequently in one document but it's
going to not appear at all and yet the
other document is going to get a low
tf-idf value so then this way we can
measure the importance of the word
throughout sorry throughout the entire
collection of data sets and here we can
see that the top 25 highest tf-idf words
in descriptions and if we also do if we
look at the mean on the right you can
see that that's going to change so we
can see that these are different worse
than what we saw in the term frequency
as being the highest but we can also we
can still have we can still have you can
see the data is telling the top
twenty-five so with this we have a
better understanding of what is going on
over all the data sets and not just
within one value overall and then we can
also look at the description term
frequency versus document frequency and
similarly for the word and here if we
look at it we can see it's very earthy
you have ocean earth land
biosphere so it's everything you
expected NASA to be and we can have
further understanding of what is going
on but then we want to see how the word
co-occur with each other so then we're
going to build this word co-occurrence
matrix and this is going to give us the
top most frequently co-occurring words
and the darker the color the more
frequently they co-occur and what we can
say is that data and product are the
most frequently co-occurring terms and
here we look at the top 10 but if we are
trying to zoom out we can see at the top
20 and we can also increase it to top 50
depending on what we want and we if we
don't list out we're going to get more
detailed analysis and a more detailed
view of the patterns that are occurring
in the network but on top of that there
is something really cool that we can do
using Seaborn which has a cluster map
which also helps us to discover the
structure in the heat maps so basically
it's going to connect create a
hierarchical structure in between the
words that co-occur together and how
frequently and here I thought it for the
top 20 word co-occurrence matrix and if
we standardize this then we have you can
see on that side a different
hierarchical clustering and we can
reveal which words conquer together and
with what frequency and this is really
nice because it also discovers the
structure in the co-occurrence matrix
it's not it doesn't just give numbers
but it shows how they connect to each
other and getting back to our main
question what we want to understand is
whether the features pulled from the
text that is the title description field
and other human supplies keywords is
descriptive of the content of the data
so in order to do this we're going to do
topic modeling so for those of you who
don't know what topic modeling is it's
an efficient way to make sense of large
volume of texts we can identify topics
which in the core text corpus who think
and categorize documents into topics and
we can associate words with topics so in
this case we're going to get all these
32,000 data set and we're going to see
if we can identify topics within this
data set and we can categorize them into
topics and we want to see how we can
associate words with this topic so who
use this topic modeling this is a very
widely used technique and
of course as I said what Nessa is trying
to do is to build the search engine and
also there are many other companies and
people out there who try to build search
engines for their marketing purpose and
for you can also use this for marketing
purpose to reveal which topics are most
interesting to a person for example
recommender products and so on so there
are several techniques of doing topic
modeling but the most common is the LDA
method so this basically is a Bayesian
inference model that is going to
associate these documents to probability
distribution over the topics and the
topics are probability distributions of
their words and then it's going to
cluster these words into topics or you
can cluster documents into a mixture of
topics and its advantages that it scales
well with growing corpus so it's going
to be a useful technique and we are
going to analyze this and of course
you're going to have to specify the
number of topics and you're going to do
an analysis you can either do an
exploratory analysis or a more detailed
analysis of how to choose the optimal
number of topics but for my analysis I
chose 25 because those was the optimal
number and then if we look at this I
just I'm not gonna show you all 25 to
bore you to death
but I'm going to show you four topics
and if you can see the I'm plotted each
topic with the ten highest most
frequently occurring words in this in
each topic and as you can see these
words are not really informative so we
can see that there are similarities
between the words that occur in the same
topic but we want to further analyze
this and gain more insight but if you
are not familiar with topic modeling you
also need to look at the to evaluate
these topics and you have to do
this with the topical here and technique
so you want to see how the words that
cook her together that are clustered
together what is their coherence so
you're going to use this topic of here
instead by calculating the UMS function
and it's going to give you a score and
based on this you're going to be able to
get which are the most coherent topics
of from this twenty five or whichever
you find that is optimal number so if I
look at my highest coherence in the NASA
dataset collection then I can see these
are my eighth highest topic coherence
clusters and if I'm looking at this and
still it's it looks that I can see words
that are synonyms things that are
correlated but I still want to gain more
insight out of this and what I'm going
to do is if I remember I told you that
each dataset has a key word has actually
several key words so I'm connecting
these key words with the topics and then
I can actually see for each key word
what are the top ten words that are
revealed from the LDA method and then if
we look at this we actually can see that
there is the meaningful pattern and we
can get information for example for the
budget topic we get financial fiscal
strategy avoidance or at cio
oops sorry budget report so basically
these are words that correspond to the
key word budget and then we have
astrophysics with trajectory studio
circular seismology we have risk
earthquake multi hazard so we can see
that the key words are basically
representative of what we of the words
within the description that were human
the assigned and then if you want to do
other clustering method you can also use
the King
method to use as a different clustering
method and then you would do a
silhouette analysis which is going to
give you the separation distance between
the resulting clusters and if you do
silhouette if you calculate the
silhouette score for the clusters that
you have you're going to basically
obtain something like I'm going to jump
on you're going to obtain something like
this which is going to be a plot of the
number of clusters and so the silhouette
score is going to be plotted as the
function of the number of clusters and
from this you can actually obtain C
which is the optimal number of clusters
for which you get the highest alert
score but you have to somewhere finds
the optimal number before it's actually
saturates because you also don't want to
go too high but you want to stay
somewhere below so if I look for example
it's five clusters I can see these words
in each cluster the top ten most
frequently occurring words and these
terms are going to be similar than the
ones that I find in LD a method but then
of course there are other techniques
that you can do and you can look at that
classification under machine learning
method like K and K nearest neighbors
you can do decision trees you can just
support vector machines or other or
night based probabilistic model to
classify these data set and since so
these are the machine learning
techniques that you can use but as I
said at the beginning I'm also network
scientist which means that I'm trying to
look at every complex network and reveal
relationships between them and look at
connections between them and analyze
their underlying network structure so in
this case I was thinking that we can
apply because network scientists in
networks in everything I was thinking
that we could apply a bipartite network
analysis and we can start analyzing the
network of description and keywords
and we're going to say that we're
connecting two words in a description if
they appear under the same keyword now
inversely you can do connect two
keywords if they share common words in
the description and this is going to
give you two different networks that you
can analyze and study structure and you
can reveal communities within these
networks and you can reveal additional
information so since I'm running out of
time I'm going to go fast for this but
there are bipartite network projections
that you can do you can either analyze
description and keywords you can analyze
the description with the title so in
this project currently I didn't look at
the titles because this they mostly
contain only projects code those are not
really informative and that don't really
help us to meaningfully search
throughout the data collection so I
excluded that from my analysis but if
you're interested you can actually do
that on your own time and you can also
look at title and keyword relationships
and if you're looking at networks we can
also analyze type of interactions we can
look at link direction of whether the
link is directed or undirected in this
case what I meaning the social network
example would be if we're looking at
Facebook it's going to be an undirected
network because if you're a friend of
mine I'm a friend of yours and if we say
that there is a connection between them
that is going to mean that it's
undirected because both of them are
connected to each other however if we're
looking at Twitter for example there's
going to be a directed connection who is
following who so based on this link
direction you can reveal additional
information and then you can look at
link weight how strong the connections
are this basically you can in this case
we looked at the co-occurrence matrix
how many times they co-occur together so
you can assign the strengths of the
connection as the weights how many times
they co-occur or for example again if I
bring up a social network
example if you look at mobile
communications networks maybe I want to
see not only if if you called me but I
also want to see how many times they
called me to actually reveal more
information about how strong our
connection is through the network and
there are other things you can do you
can look at structural network
properties like the degree distributions
which is going to reveal connectivity
patterns you can see whether the nodes
have connections similar number of
connections or whether we have hubs
which has degree higher number of
connections average degrees and you can
reveal these communities and clusters
and how densely they are connected so
there are many things you can look at
and then I'm just going to leave it at
this because I'm running out of time you
can make all these nice visualizations
and you can do additional analysis and
you can find us for example in this case
I brought you the top 100 most frequent
words that are occurring in the
description text and the external nodes
are the ones that are the top most
frequent word and as we can see here for
example there is already an information
out there that the nodes with the
highest connectivity are not all the
same as the most frequently co-occurring
word so I'll leave it at this I'll just
wrap it up that the network structures
are a powerful tool to capture
additional information about
interconnected systems and so yeah one
more thing there is a what another thing
that NASA is looking at is what are the
important connections between NASA
dataset and other datasets outside of
NASA in the US government and as I said
that this was an initiative of making
publicly available all these government
data sets so that they increase the
visibility and transparency so you can
go on this website and download the
metadata for EPA NSF or all the other
data so that you can think of
and for this eye on the bottom you're
going to see this package that I'm going
to upload and you can just pip install
PI OpenGov and it's going to load for
you or the JSON file and then using the
Jupiter notebooks that I made available
you can also read all this topic
modeling and analysis that I've done and
the PI NASA is done by one of our data
not colleagues here Bruno and basically
this library is also just people install
it and it's going to load for you the
open NASA dataset and so the takeaways
are here and thank you for your time
[Applause]
so I don't work for NASA so this is this
is something so this is basically an
initiative so big we become NASA data
not but we don't get paid
we're doing our project in our free time
and we're working on whatever we want at
whatever pace we want we have meetings
webinars with NASA employees and NASA
data scientists to brainstorm on topics
that we can work together on but this is
all something that you do as a volunteer
basically NASA doesn't have money for
that just for stickers